et benjamin bitton pour le casting de
danse avec les stars alors il y aurait
loana côté contacté loana qui aurait
contacté whip seulement il y aurait
esther building alors est ce terme
holding et c'est les brassards rouges un
accord qui dépasse tim holding
[Rires]
bref qu'on se la joue et luan et noah
d'alexandra louis et thomas jouannet
elle est très sympathique très simple
objet demande à chaque fois qu'ils c'est
à chaque saison alors si elle allait
faire une émission de magie juste après
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'on connaît c'est cathy guetta
et passez moi populaire qui étaient
passés vos barrières attendait après
alors que là je vous le dis et semaine
ceux qui nous rejoignent
c'est ce qu'ils ont été contactés mais
chez le dix danses avec les stars un
moment ils peuvent me contacter je vous
le dit barack obama
ils se retrouvent avec non mais voilà
ils balancent quoi à balancer mais
qu'ils se retrouveraient bas il se
retrouve avec un tri car on va pas se
mentir non non vous avez commencé à
m'appeler et tout j'ai dit non on a déjà
dit non et puis après il ya eu ce but
qui menace en rien eu
voilà je vous dire dans cette les stars
ils ont contacté aussi et d'idées preto
moi je connais voilà et non une
excellente avec angèle
alors si elle va pas bien comme ça
voilà il faut mettre le triangle là
c'est le concert qu'il a fait sur une
bande d'arrêt d'urgence
la sandrine quétier je suis au pay à
sandrine quétier également qui a été
contacté
sandrine qui était présentatrice du
programme je la vois mal maintenant
revenir la queue entre les jambes de
faire condamner le contenu s'il avait
fait vincent cerruti avait fait candidat
alors qu'il a présenté des années
l'émission danse avec les stars sorti le
premier on s'en souvient pas si on sort
alors y'a gabriel gros également le
chanteur du groupe qui john hight tech
que j'adore
vincent de diane qui a été contacté sa
mère à pattes ça sert à rien de rigolo
et non pas parce que c'est votre ami qui
m'a pas m
je vous le dis voilà je vous dis pas
façon de gianni les mois jours du
malheureux théâtre c'est pas pour les
faire ce cas il joue mal on au tertre
ah ben voilà qu'alors alors bien sûr
alors parce qu'on joue malraux 400
affaires danse avec les stars
non mais c'est un acte alors dsk raconte
une actualité forte
écoutez moi je pense qu'il ferait mieux
d'aller faire danse avec les stars et
victoria abril que j'aime beaucoup moi
je pense qu'elle va y aller dribbler
ce serait un très bon un très bon cas
c'est ça oui tout ça ne me fait pas
rêver en plus ça il démarre avec ça donc
ça veut dire normalement quand vous
contact et victoria abril vous vous
retrouvez avec mathilda may et n'aura
qu'à l'aller mais à la limite tom
novembre
voilà maintenant mais il faut pas se
mentir il ya quelques rêves de noms
ronflants qui ne viendront pas et tous
les noms moyens que vous citez irons et
ce sera dense avec les tocards saison
vous soyez c'est un tocard moscato nazis
le nom mais l'accepter bah oui mais non
mais s'il vous plaît il dit comme ici
quoi c'est pareil à 6 un petit peu le
même principe
il appelle des dizaines des déserts des
dizaines de personnes en faut en faisant
quoi qu ils les veulent absolument une
fois ils ont une centaine son sac et sa
solde il faudrait une réunion où il dit
sur les 250 m
déjà qu'ils ont été appelés ici c'est
bon mais non vous gave
non j'ai pas isolé vole un parasol
saleh